bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons ensemble le sommaire de cette
édition le cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa à
Saint-Cyr-l'École vous propose de vivre
une expérience bouleversante et
humaniste vendredi 28 mars le
documentaire au bord du monde se
rapprochée suivi d'une rencontre avec le
réalisateur toutes les précisions avec
notre invité jusqu'au 11 mars la salle
des expositions de Guyancourt hommage
aux femmes pas n'importe lesquels les
héroïnes occupent le haut de l'affiche
samedi 12 avril la batterie à Guyancourt
reçoit le chanteur Tiken Jah Fakoly son
retour sur la scène musicale et marquée
par la sortie d'un nouvel album Nicolas
Gervais la rencontrer
projetez vendredi 28 mars au cinéma Les
Yeux d'Elsa à Saint-Cyr-l'École le
documentaire de Klaus Bruxelles pardon
au bord du monde donne la parole à ceux
que l'on voit mais que l'on entend pas
souvent le réalisateur a suivi pendant
un an à Paris une dizaines de sans-abris
Pascal Michel Christine et les autres en
survivent sur les trottoirs dans le
métro ou encore sous les ponts quel est
le regard sur le monde comment parler de
ceux qui dorment dans la rue c'est ce
dont nous allons parler ce soir avec
Bertrand Pignier bonsoir vous êtes
responsable du cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa à
Saint-Cyr-l'École alors avant que vous
nous expliquez en fait pourquoi vous
avez envie d'organiser cet événement je
vous propose qu'on regarde la
bande-annonce tout simplement pour nous
mettre dans le ton
homme ça ça m'a fait plaisir le gars il
s'arrêtait là en voiture on m'a dit j'ai
des courses pour vous il m'a ramené deux
sacs
il m'a dit ça ça met de la part de ma
femme ça c'est ma part de ma belle-mère
pratiquement tous les jours je fais je
fais la revue de presse de 3 6 journaux
tout ce qui est scientifique tout ce qui
est social social justice je le sont des
droits de l'homme
à 60 balais je sens qu'il fait encore
l'été pour remonter la porte faut pas
trop déprimer sur les mauvaises choses
il peut encore y avoir les bonnes choses
qu'est-ce que vous faites quand vous
avez froid
il y a des matins je me lève et j'en ai
vraiment marre à fond à chaque fois
qu'il y a le Marathon de Paris qui se
court moi je cours le Marathon de Paris
si on pouvait vraiment se mettre quelque
part mais on dérange toujours
c'est comme si il considérait pas ce que
tu es là tout est fini pour toi c'est
même plus l'appel de s'arrêter c'est
même plus la peine d'écouter tiens la
non réponse au problème qui nous
maintient ici
c'est ça le pire
qu'est-ce qui vous a intéressé dans la
démarche du réalisateur
j'ai découvert le film d'abord par par
des affiches en fait par une manière de
de proposer une photographie d'une
personne extrêmement démunie sur les
Champs-Élysées et du coup ce contraste
en fait m'a frappé c'est le contraste
qui qui m'a fait me dire qu'il y avait
quelque chose d'intéressant en tout cas
d'intrigant dans ce documentaire
donc voilà donc je suis allé chercher
enfin je suis allé demander le avoir le
film j'ai pu le découvrir ça a été
vraiment un choc assez bouleversant pour
la simple et bonne raison que c'est pas
un film qui cherche à faire du
sensationnalisme c'est un film qui
cherche simplement à prendre le temps de
regarder les gens en face les gens qu'on
a pas l'habitude de regarder en face
exactement
on est dans un documentaire justement
comme vous le disiez on n'est pas dans
le misérabilisme du tout dans le
sentimental un peu un peu lourd comme
certains documentaires avec des
commentaires etc elle a pas du tout
alors quel regard justement vous portez
sur la manière dont sont présentés
c'est sans abri
justement c'est ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure les deux adjectifs qui sont
qui me sont venus pour décrire le film
c'est bouleversant et humaniste je pense
que la meilleure définition c'est
humaniste c'est un film qui regarde ces
gens qu'on a l'habitude de de croiser
sans les voir de
qui on a l'habitude de jeter un coup
d'oeil tout en tout en passant son
chemin en fait tout à coup ce
documentaire prend une heure et demie
pour nous proposer de nous arrêter avec
eux de prendre le temps avec eux de
prendre le temps de les écouter
et pas dans et pas de les écouter dans
un quotidien
qui serait le quotidien de la misère ou
de la douleur ou de la difficulté ou de
la fin ou du froid c'est vraiment un
documentaire qui prend le temps de leur
laisser la parole sur le quotidien la
vie la vie de tous les jours
leurs pensées sur le monde et leur
rapport au monde et qui le fait avec un
sens de la beauté qui qui est jamais
proposé dans ce genre de travail sur les
SDF et les clochards justement sur la
forme en tant que professionnel du
cinéma
le choix quelles sont enfin selon votre
avis là sur le choix du réalisateur
d'une esthétique très forte on a un
contrat justement entre ces gens démunis
et puis un décor Paris de nuit ville
lumière des lieux de richesse une beauté
vraiment des décors et ce contraste
comme ça on a aussi des longs silences
jamais de gros plan intrusif c'est
toujours des plans larges fixes
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces partis
pris du réalisateur
ce que j'en pense c'est que c'est que
c'est du cinéma tout simplement c'est
que c'est la grande différence avec avec
tout ce qui peut être proposé autour de
ces sujets là souvent on nous propose
des des plans sur l'action du Samu
Social l'action des des gens qui
viennent donner à manger aider ces
gens-là là il s'agit pas du tout de ça
il s'agit vraiment de sans vouloir
rendre beau la misère il s'agit pas du
tout de ça dans le film il s'agit
simplement de de rendre à ces gens et à
cette misère un véritable statut et les
intégrer comme ça dans un pari filmé
réellement comme la plus belle ville du
monde enfin c'est difficile à décrire en
fait on voit quelques images à l'écran
un Paris carte postale peut-être sauf
que des cartes postales on n'en voit pas
beaucoup comme des comme ça aux
aventures des buralistes là il y a
vraiment il y a vraiment une idée de
photographie et de cinéma il y a le
temps qui passe nous est proposé dans
dans ses plans là comme on l'a entendu
dans la bande-annonce la seule musique
proposée c'est de la musique d'opéra et
du coup ça apporte une grandeur et pas
une grandeur factice ça apporte une
véritable grandeur humaniste ça
réintègre ces gens qui qu'on pourrait
penser être la plus grande laideur de
notre monde actuel on est toujours en
train de dire il faut qu'il n'y ait plus
de SDF etc je dis pas qu'il faut qu'il y
en ait je dis simplement que tout à coup
ça remet ces gens dans le monde dans
notre monde
c'est Excel donc le réalisateur qui n'a
pas pu être sur le plateau ce soir du
kiosque mais qui nous a accordé une
interview téléphonique il nous parle
justement de ces intentions quant à ce
tournage et en quoi ça l'a bouleversé
qu'on voit de partout à Paris et c'est
les gens qu'on voit donc en permanence
mais qu'on entend jamais il me semblait
vraiment important de de faire un film
on leur donne la parole ils peuvent
s'exprimer donc c'est pour ça que dans
il n'y a pas de commentaires et
d'analyses parce que justement c'était
un film où je voulais écouter simplement
et voir ce qu'ils ont à dire sur notre
monde à nous qu'est-ce que ces personnes
qu'on entend jamais peuvent nous
apprendre de la vie
qui m'a poussé à faire le film tout
simplement quand on leur a dit justement
qu'on voulait faire le film sur une
durée d'un an
ça se met on leur a dit que on
reviendrait les voir pendant un an et
que les les entretiens ne seraient pas
préparés à l'avance mais ce serait
des livres durée deux trois heures et ce
qu'on voit dans le film en fait plus que
des réponses et des questions
d'interview
sont des ce sont des
traits en fait de discussion entre amis
d'aventure dans laquelle je me suis
lancé par curiosité j'en suis sorti
bouleversé et transformer parce que j'ai
rencontré une
générosité et un accueil chaleureux que
je ne m'attendais pas à trouver en fait
chez une personne une population aussi
des favorisée la chose essentielle et je
pense que crucial est fondamentale c'est
que chaque citoyen citoyen comprenne que
nous avons tous notre responsabilité et
que ce qui fait le plus souffrir ces
personnes plus que de ne pas avoir de
logement ce qui est évidemment et qui
est épouvantable mais au-delà de ça je
pense que le plus
terrible c'est de sentir qu'on n'existe
plus aux yeux de nos concitoyens et que
les les passants des troubles le regard
aussi le regard de regarde avec avec une
absence de dignité ce qui me touche le
plus maintenant c'est que je reçois des
coups de fil ou les messages de
d'association humanitaire qui qui nous
remercient parce que grâce au film il y
a de nouveau bénévoles qui s'en vient et
ça c'est super et moi je demande
j'invite tout le monde à s'engager comme
il peut parce que les personnes qui
perdent pour moi ces personnes là les
garder avec un sourire et dire bonjour
monsieur bonjour madame et je pense que
ça change déjà énormément
voilà donc redonner de la dignité assez
ces personnes alors c'est une forme
finalement d'engagement aussi pour vous
de proposer ce documentaire à la
programmation qu'est-ce que vous
aimeriez que vendredi le public retienne
qu'est-ce que j'aimerais
tout simplement j'aimerais déjà qu'il y
ait des qui est du monde qui viennent et
que par cela on montre à se réalisateur
que que cette question qui l'a touché
qui l'a bouleversé qui l'a intéressé
d'abord mais qu'il l'a transformé est
une question qui touche et qui est dont
les gens
souhaitent s'emparer parce que je pense
vraiment qu'il y a une possibilité de se
transformer en fait en voyant en voyant
ce documentaire moi-même comme il le dit
j'ai
pas partie de ces gens qui croisent des
sans-abris qui leur disent pas bonjour
et alors que j'aime bien dire bonjour
aux gens même quand je les connais pas
et là je me dis bah oui peut-être qu'il
va falloir juste changer ça j'aimerais
que les gens viennent
pour découvrir une très belle œuvre
cinématographique et pour entrer dans un
vrai questionnement humaniste par
rapport à eux-mêmes et par rapport à ces
gens pour cela rendez vous au cinéma les
yeux des lézards vendredi 20h45 tarif
unique 3 euros 50 merci Bertrand merci à
vous alors maintenant je vous propose de
découvrir une exposition hommage aux
femmes pas n'importe lesquels les
héroïnes sont en haut de l'affiche de la
salle des expositions de Guyancourt
Sabrina nous en donne un aperçu
Catwoman Eve sœur Emmanuelle des femmes
des héroïnes qui ont marqué notre
imaginaire mais qui est réellement cette
héroïne qui fascine tant
trois parties on va dire dans cette
exposition une première partie qui est
plus documentaire historique on montre
en fait des des femmes qui ont marqué
l'histoire il y a ensuite un deuxième
espace qui est l'espace principal de
l'exposition qui est consacré à la
contemporain avec donc des œuvres
d'artistes qui ont
réfléchi travaillaient donc sur la
notion de représentation de la femme et
puis la troisième partie dans laquelle
on se trouve et une partie consacrée à
la bande dessinée 12 artistes français
et étrangers exposent leurs œuvres 12
visions de l'héroïne pour la photographe
Sandrine Elberg celle-ci a une double
vie je présente ici en fait un travail
qui s'appelle Paris burlesque qui
concerne en fait des photographies de
femmes qui se produisent sur scène dans
des cabarets parisiens en fait j'ai
décidé de les photographier chez elle
dans un univers quotidien dans leur
costume de scène ce qui m'a intéressé
vraiment c'est de mélanger cet univers
quotidien de leurs appartements à Paris
avec justement ce costume et ce
personnage qu'elles sont créés pour la
scène à quelques mètres une étrange
pièce attire l'attention du visiteur
très vite celui-ci se laisse transporter
par une mélodie qu'il connaît par cœur
je présente une pièce qui s'appelle
happy birthday Mister président qu'on
entend derrière moi et qui ont en fait
chanté par cette sculpture un peu
spectacle Titus ban qui est en hommage à
Marilyn Monroe et c'est toute cette
époque en fait de de merveilleux du rêve
américain qui s'écoule un petit peu s'il
Marilyn dans toute sa ça sa faiblesse à
vulnérabilité c'est ces moments là où
l'héroïne peut être bascule qui
m'intéresse beaucoup peut-être le public
sera dérouté par la vision de l'artiste
femme de fiction d'une autre époque où
femme du quotidien il appartient à
chacun de choisir laquelle mériterait
à l'occasion du vernissage le 27 mars le
jury décernera quatre prix un par
catégorie et le coup de cœur du jury
enfin un dernier dédié à la sélection du
public sera également remise ce jour-là
les votes sont d'ores et déjà ouvert à
tous
samedi 12 avril la batterie à Guyancourt
reçoit le chanteur Tiken Jah Fakoly son
retour sur la scène musicale et marquée
par la sortie le 2 juin d'un nouvel
album Nicolas Gervais la rencontrer
artiste reggae francophone un
contournable il est originaire de Côte
d'Ivoire et sortir en juin son nouvel
album dernier rappel ils sont en
concerts notamment le 12 avril à la
batterie à Guyancourt voici Tiken Jah
Fakoly dans le kiosque
je fais une pause d'abord de deux ans
donc j'ai consacré à l'agriculture donc
là aussi c'était pour faire passer un
message important la jeunesse africaine
donc je dis aux jeunes rester ici notre
place ici et si nous voulons que nos
enfants se retrouvent dans une Afrique
différente de celle que nous on connaît
aujourd'hui dont on se plaint allez va
falloir planter la graine l'arroser et
puis peut-être nos petits enfants ou les
enfants de nos petits enfants viendront
récolter parce que en Afrique nous avons
la terre nous avons l'eau nous avons le
soleil dans la plupart des pays donc il
y a pas de raison qu'on parle de crise
alimentaire si les jeunes restaient au
village en même temps ces deux ans m'ont
permis de réfléchir et là j'ai compris
que nous avons une très grande
responsabilité dans le retard de
l'Afrique nous les Africains nous-mêmes
parce que on entend toujours que les
jours les gens viennent changer les
choses pour nous et donc voilà le
message de l'album c'est nous avons une
stabilité prenons nos responsabilités
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut aller faire
des révolutions ou casser etc parce
qu'en Afrique nous avons besoin de tout
construire quand on a besoin de
construire on n'a pas on a le devoir de
ne pas détruire il faut aussi respecter
nos institutions voilà il faut dénoncer
la dictature il faut dénoncer la
mauvaise gouvernance il faut dénoncer
tout ce qui ne va pas mais à partir du
moment où il y a un président qui est
élu
il faut le respecter les présidents en
Afrique qui sont
ils sont comme sur les tabourets alors
qu'il faut être sûr des sièges il faut
protéger le pouvoir
ils ont peur qu'il y ait un coup d'état
donc il faut protéger le ciel et se
concentrer sur le volant donc c'est pas
évident bien sûr il y a les injustices
contre le le continent africain qui est
une paradoxe historique l'Afrique est
l'un des continents le plus riche et
l'Afrique à l'une des populations les
plus pauvres c'est quand même paradoxal
d'être riche et pauvre donc c'est des
sujets comme ça que j'aborde dans le
prochain album qui s'appelle dernière
dernier appel
il est important qu'on prouve que
effectivement que l'Afrique est la
source du reggae donc voilà c'est
pourquoi on utilise justement comme la
chorale balafon qui est un peu le violon
traditionnel en Afrique il y a une
dizaine de semaines traditionnels qui a
été utilisé dans ce prochain album
diaspora donc un message qu'on adresse à
la diaspora africaine dans le monde pour
leur rappeler que dans les années 50 ou
de 50 à 70
la connexion entre la diaspora africaine
dans le monde et ceux qui menait le
combat sur le continent a été a été
déterminant dans la libération du
continent africain aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que notre diaspora elle est
plus concentrée sur l'économie elle est
plus en train de chercher l'argent pour
aller investir c'est bien mais on
souhaite qu'il s'engage aussi
politiquement
donc Patrice qui a été invité sur le
titre tout match confusion mais voilà
qui parle de pollution et puis il y a
aussi les cas qui est invité sur le
titre en anglais aussi je pense que
c'était devenu de toute façon
indispensable en ma carrière parce que
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance
d'avoir une carrière qui commence à être
vraiment voilà mondial mais ça devient
indispensable parce que le message il
doit aller partout aujourd'hui dans le
monde
c'est un hommage à la mère de ma fille
voilà j'ai une fille qui a 26 ans
aujourd'hui donc qui est né quand
j'avais 18 ans donc j'étais très jeune
donc sa mère était en nous étions
fiancés moi j'avais pas de boulot vous
savez ça faisait pas trop joli d'être
rastable vous vouloir chanter pour moi
c'était impossible de me marier parce
que j'avais pas pouvoir souvenir aux
besoins de ma famille et donc tata elle
m'a attendu pendant 10 ans elle m'a
attendu pendant 10 ans et
au bout de 10 ans effectivement elle a
sous la pression de ses parents elle a
dû se marier de force à quelqu'un
d'autre
et puis je crois qu'elle a fait deux ans
dans ce foyer et puis un jour j'ai
appris sa mort c'est une personne qui a
beaucoup souffert pour moi et voilà j'ai
décidé de rendre hommage
en avril donc on a décidé de visiter de
revisiter les petites salles que nous
ont soutenu il y a 15-20 ans en France
une manière pour nous de leur dire merci
de nous avoir soutenu au début et puis
l'album va sortir le 2 juin et puis
voilà après on va attaquer les festivals
ça serait Tiken Jah on retrouve Aurelia
dans le kiosque
nous sommes bien mercredi c'est donc
l'heure des sorties ciné au micro dès le
dimanche une relation père fils
extrêmement forte et un film qui faut
vraiment aller voir moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé ce film il est très émouvant
des grands films comme Rain Man à
l'époque
on peut qu'être sensible quand on a la
préoccupation des personnes en situation
de handicap c'était formidable j'étais
avec mon fils et c'est un très bon
esprit et voilà c'est très bien ça passe
un très bon moment j'ai beaucoup aimé
beaucoup aimé c'est un beau film un
hymne à la vie voilà
franchement j'étais enthousiasmée le
rapport
au décor et sublime le trouble entre le
théâtre et le cinéma et fantastique le
message sur la vie et m'a beaucoup
touchée
bonne musique bonnes actrices on s'amuse
du début jusqu'à la fin on rigole
beaucoup très amusant et en
correspondance avec la vie actuelle
c'est bien un mal franchement il y a de
l'action ça peut être bien
l'histoire est vraiment vraiment
quoi il y a rien à dire
alors cinéphile c'est aussi l'occasion
d'entendre un professionnel du cinéma
nous donner son coup de coeur et cette
semaine c'est Cyril Adad projectionniste
à l'espace Philippe Noiret des
Clayes-sous-Bois
cette semaine le coup de coeur de
l'Espace Philippe Noiret et le dessin
animé tant Tilda réalisé par Jacques
Rémy girer tant Ilda est une amoureuse
de la nature elle conserve dans son
musée végétal pas mal de plantes qui
dont certaines commencent à disparaître
de la de la planète parallèlement une
céréale et développée par des industries
et donc du coup cette céréale est censée
éradiquer la fin dans le monde le
réalisateur nous compte une fable écolo
tendrement drôle qui est destiné à faire
sourire le spectateur et le sensibilité
par la même occasion sur l'écologie et
les problèmes d'OGM visuellement le film
est tout simplement splendide
l'animation est vraiment très très bien
fait les plantes sont capables de
grandir façon géante
les bénéfices non graphiques
c'est une révolution grâce à dilemme la
fin dans le monde est en voie de
disparition
tantilda est un film à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace Philippe Noiret
cette émission est à présent terminée
merci de sur tvfils vous retrouve donc
la semaine prochaine en direct à 18h30 à
mercredi